bienvenue à tous styles sac et tv c'est
reparti pour un tour nous voici au
plateau des projets s'est amorcé un lieu
qui nous permet d'appréhender votre
territoire qui se construit se réinvente
c'est un lieu de concertation des
changes un outil pédagogique aussi pour
les enseignants et les élèves comme ceux
du lycée saint nicolas diguiny ou ceux
du lycée henri iv à paris vous entendrez
leurs témoignages élèves qui choisiront
peut-être d'intégrer l'université paris
saclay retour dans cette émission sur
cette rentrée inédite
c'est la première pour le campus paris
saclay à suivre les explications du
président de l'université paris saclay
gilles bloch imaginer construire ce pôle
d'excellence entraîne aussi des
questions pratiques comment chauffer
tous les bâtiments ce qui existe mais
ceux qui vont se construire aussi et
bien la réponse est sous nos pieds nous
allons vous expliquer tout cela enfin
connaissez vous les boucs
il s'agit de cours ouverts en lui sur
internet les plus grandes écoles s'y
mettent comme polytechnique hec
c'est notre rubrique décryptage et nous
terminerons cette émission avec notre
agenda
tous les évènements à ne surtout pas
rater
mais d'abord retour sur cette rentrée
inédite la première pour le campus paris
saclay la première pour dix mille
étudiants en master et 1500 doctorants
paris saclay c'est aussi une marque qui
se matérialise tout de suite les
explications de gilles bloch le
président de l'université paris saclay
la rentrée 2015 de l'université paris
saclay
c'est la première rentrée où
l'université en tant que tel va
accueillir des étudiants au sein des
établissements qui sont membres de
l'université paris saclay avec trois
sets très marquant d'abord tous les
étudiants ont une carte d'étudiant pour
logo de l'université paris saclay qui
leur donnera vraiment un nouveau
sentiment d'appartenance ces cartes
porteront aussi la marque des
établissements et nous devons créer
aussi ce sentiment plus collectif au
niveau de paris saclay
c'est aussi la première fois que nous
accueillons des étudiants en master ces
master ont été accrédités au niveau de
l'université paris saclay 49 mentions de
master nous avons procédé pendant tout
l'été à l'identification des étudiants à
travers des candidatures à leur
répartition dans les différentes
mentions et nous attendons environ dix
mille étudiants pour cette rentrée ce
sera la première fois que les masters
seront vraiment mutualisée au niveau de
l'université
il y aura aussi des étudiants doctorat
les écoles doctorales ont été totalement
fusionnée au niveau des 18
établissements environ 1500 qui étudiant
sont attendus qui l'a aussi seront le
fer de lance de notre université
dernier point je n'ai pas évoqué c'est
la recherche
cette rentrée sera aussi le moment où la
signature commune de l'université paris
saclay va être lancé tous les articles
entre huit et dix mille suivant comment
on les contres chaque année porteront
dorénavant cette nouvelle marque
université paris saclay qui permettra de
nous rendre plus visible depuis
l'international
parmi les futurs étudiants de
l'université paris saclay il y aura
peut-être des élèves du lycée saint
nicolas guinea ou ceux du lycée henri iv
à paris
ils ont pu se rendre compte des défis
relevés par votre territoire et surtout
des opportunités et à ce pôle
d'excellence en venant ici au plateau
des projets à or c'est nous les avons
suivis lors de cette visite
donc là comme vous pouvez le voir et
d'être sur un territoire gigantesque et
une opération de vestiges et d'oreille
dans le but de développer du logement de
l'emploi de la croissance à l'échelle
nationale notre lycée est un lycée en
fête agricole et donc mon groupe
d'élèves là ici présents sont des
seconds général mais ils ont un module
d'exploration qui est spécifique au
ministère de l'agriculture à l'ancienne
morricone et qui s'appelle écologie
agriculture territoire développement
durable est donc dans le cadre de ce
module
j'ai cherché donc à travailler sur un
territoire en particulier proche du
lycée et a montré un petit peu la
problématique d'aménagement les conflits
d'usagé éventuellement qu'il peut y
avoir sur ce territoire
les spécificités et donc le plateau de
saclay c'est un très bon territoire
justement pour enquêter dessus
pour les élèves c'est intéressant parce
que c'est s'intéresser à différents
domaines donc il ya différents acteurs
surtout donc finalement c'est en
pluridisciplinarité avec plusieurs
disciplines l'histoire-géo l'agronomie
l'économie l'écologie aussi
l'aménagement qui est prévu donc avec la
densification d'entreprise de structures
de recherche de structures
d'enseignement
pour nous de toute façon c'est un atout
pour pour l'établissement parce que
c'est une façon aussi de faire venir des
élèves qui pourront faire une poursuite
d'études ensuite sur ce territoire
sachant que nous nous avons un internat
nous avons des élèves car il possible de
loin donc c'est vrai que c'est
voilà c'est un une attractivité sur en
plus on va dire pour notre établissement
le projet paris s'incline et bénéfique
sur tous les plans au trio est ce qu'il
y aura de nouvelles entreprises des
dépassements y aura des logements y aura
des espaces ouverts à la base mais dès
que je voulais les faire à la sorbonne
donc maintenant avec tout ce que j'ai
appris aujourd'hui
j'envisage aussi de pentu continuer
d'étudier
et maintenant une question pratique
comment chauffer comment refroidir ce
site gigantesque et bien la réponse elle
est sous nos pieds grâce à la géothermie
profonde c'est tout un réseau chaleur et
froid qui va être mise en oeuvre
objectif développer une énergie locale
propre renouvelable
voyez ce reportage
le réseau de chaleur et de froid paris
saclay pourquoi avoir fait ça pour trois
raisons d'abord c'est une énergie locale
ce qui était une garantie forte
deuxièmement c'est une énergie
renouvelable et propre décarbonés très
bonne performance environnementale et
troisièmement c'est une énergie a pris
contrôle et nous en connaissons le coup
aujourd'hui et demain il n'ya pas d'aléa
de marchés sur le coût de cet économiste
une grande sécurité pour ceux qui vont
devoir se chauffer ou se refroidir sur
le plateau
le système est basé sur la géothermie
donc il s'agit d'aller récupérer à 700
mètres de profondeur de l'eau à 28
degrés on va faire circuler dans une
boucle dit réseau tempérer cette boucle
de tempérer va permettre de produire de
la chaleur du froid mais aussi aux
bâtiments d'échangés de l'énergie parce
qu'il serait excédentaire ou déficitaire
dans leur profil visage l'ensemble de ce
réseau irrigue d'une centaine de
bâtiments qui vont être tous connectés à
une fibre optique dit fibre énergie qui
va permettre de créer le smart grid
campus saclay et tous les bâtiments vont
pouvoir agir sur un système global entre
la production et leurs besoins de
manière à optimiser la consommation
d'énergie de chaque bâtiment
nous avons sur ce site existants et à
venir des bâtiments avec un profil
énergétique très particulier qui ont des
processus lourd pour pour créer du froid
et qui donc rejette du show grâce à la
boucle que nous allons créer dans le
cadre de ce réseau ce show ne sera pas
perdu et envoyé dans l'atmosphère est
remis sur la boucle pour chauffer les
voisins
le projet de réalisation de cet ouvrage
cette infrastructure s'étale sur sept
ans donc de 2016 à 2021
on va créer une vingtaine de kilomètres
de réseau une centaine de sous stations
une centrale géothermique et des
centrales d'appoint secours pour fournir
le chaud le froid et garantir la
continuité du service toute l'année
le réseau de chaleur et de froid à paris
saclay va très vite devenir une réalité
nous avons la contrainte est quelque
part la chance d'être tirée par les
premiers arrivés de bâtiments sur le
plateau et vous voyez que les chantiers
sont aujourd'hui nombreux sur le plateau
ces bâtiments qui sont en train de
sortir de terre seront desservies par le
réseau de chaleur et de froid et donc le
déploiement de cette infrastructure
énergétique est déjà engagée et doit
aller très vite pour pouvoir les
satisfaire
avant de vous dévoiler l'agenda du mois
connaissez-vous les boucs
il s'agit de cours massif en ligne un
enseignement qui se fait sur internet il
suffit d'avoir un ordinateur comme celui
ci les grandes écoles s'y mettent comme
polytechnique ou hec
c'est notre rubrique décryptage
vous êtes passionné par les nouvelles
technologies vous rêvez créer votre
start up dans rejoindre une nous avons
créé ce cours pour vous l'e-book en fait
massive online au punk aussi ce sont des
cours massif en ligne ouvert au public
le plus large possible et présentant les
sujets extrême des sujets extrêmement
divers nous avons un cours spécifique
alix sur la création d'entreprises
innovantes mais nous avons décidé en
lien avec hec de créer un cours sur
création et développement d'une
entreprise technologique avec le
développement des moûts qu il nous a
semblé utile d'explorer ces nouveaux
thermique territoire de transmission du
savoir avec ces nouveaux dispositifs qui
ne consiste pas simplement à donner des
cours en ligne mais également à créer
une interaction de plusieurs milliers de
personnes sur des forums de discussion
et donc pour nous le lancement de ce
mook était une sorte d' initiatives de
recherche développement pour tester
d'avoir un échange avec avec des publics
avec lesquels on échangeait pas
naturellement ce qui nous a amené à
lancer ce mook qui à ce jour a totalisé
plus de dix mille cinq cents inscrits
venant de 140 pays différents avec donc
la structure traditionnelle d'un book à
savoir des sessions vidéo est allé sur
sur cinq semaines à raison d'une heure
de vidéo tous les mois et toute une
série de des changes sur un forum des
quiz
évidemment en l'espace de cinq heures
cumulées de vidéos
on ne se substitue pas à une formation à
hec ou à polytechnique ou un master in
business administration
mais on fait passer des messages
essentiels et on est le catalyseur d'une
discussion stratégique
il s'agit de mettre à disposition du
plateau de saclay ses contenus qui sont
déjà portée non seulement par des
enseignants des experts et des
entrepreneurs de l'x mais par des
entrepreneurs et des experts issus de
l'ensemble de l'université plateau de
saclay et d'emblée dans la structuration
de ce mook notre intention a été
d'ouvrir cela pour devenir un des outils
de référence en matière de
sensibilisation à la création
d'entreprises innovantes et à la
création d'entreprises technologiques en
particulier
voilà pour l'essentiel de l'actualité de
votre territoire tout de suite un coup
d'oeil sur votre agenda le tech'innove
fils aura lieu le 11 février 2016 mais
si vous voulez y participer en tant
qu'entrepreneur il faut absolument
envoyer votre candidature avant le
mercredi 11 novembre
là aussi plus d'informations sur
l'adresse qui suit les 2 3 et 4 décembre
c'est le salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise qui se tiendra porte
maillot à paris
le pps participent à l'événement parmi
les temps forts la première édition des
trophées 6000 nouveaux usages vous
pouvez y participer
plus d'informations sur leur site enfin
n'oublions pas les comités de suivi de
chantier ils auront lieu ici même au
plateau des projets à or c'est pour le
quartier du moulin ce sera le 16
novembre pour le quartier de l'école
polytechnique ce sera le 7 décembre
voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro de paris saclay tv d'ici
là vous pouvez rester informés grâce à
notre site internet ppr point fr